fue anunciado como un regreso triunfal a
las calles del movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos en toda francia pero
principalmente en la capital cientos de
manifestantes atendieron el llamado a
marchar por primera vez desde que se
impuso el confinamiento a principios de
año el movimiento puede tener ya dos
años de antigüedad pero para los
activistas la lucha está lejos de haber
terminado he estado saliendo a la calle
desde el 17 de noviembre de 2018 para
asegurar un mejor futuro para nuestros
niños y para evitar que este gobierno y
otros nos quiten nuestros derechos tan
duramente ganados puristas de audio mis
de agoco no estoy luchando por mejores
salarios por una vida mejor y no hay que
olvidar las pensiones y la seguridad
social
dos manifestaciones separadas se
llevaron a cabo en parís aunque la
primera se desarrolló sin incidentes la
segunda terminó en violencia las
autoridades dicen que los grupos de
manifestantes no se siguieron a la ruta
autorizada por la policía los agentes
antidisturbios intervinieron disparando
gas lacrimógeno también se enfrentaron a
un puñado de manifestantes radicales
conocidos como black block
que quemaron un coche y prendieron fuego
a varios contenedores más de 250
personas fueron arrestadas los
organizadores esperaban una
participación masiva pero las cifras
fueron pequeñas en comparación con las
de hace dos años cuando miles de
personas participaron en manifestaciones
en toda francia como reacción al aumento
de la desigualdad social